[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
unsere freundin lily wird in drei tagen
18 und ich habe mir gedacht komm ich mag
keine torte also eine richtige torte
eine große torte zum achtzehnten
geburtstag gewünscht hat sie sich eine
torte in rosa und minz richtig schön und
bunt und ich hoffe dass ich ihren
erwartungen gerecht werde und sie mit
dieser dort überraschen kann
ich hab mir jetzt vorgestellt ich mache
eine zweistöckige torte unten mit dem
durchschnitt von 28 cm oben 22 so eine
richtig schöne große torte die reicht
für 30 40 oder auch 50 personen je
nachdem wieviel natürlich auch gegessen
wird ich werde jetzt die böden
vorbereiten aus einer masse ist schön
locker und leicht und vor allem bleiben
sie sehr saftig denn sie hatte erst in
drei tagen geburtstag und heute am
ersten tag back ich die böden und bereit
noch ein bisschen deko vor
ich sage jetzt die zutaten für die 22 cm
torte die stehen nämlich schon bereit
für die römer verwende ich 225 gramm
weiche butter 180 gramm puderzucker
etwas vanille extrakt 11 gelbe 11 eiweiß
eine prise salz noch mal 180 gramm
zucker
ich habe ich 225 gramm mehl 2 esslöffel
milch oder rum und blaue zucker stolzen
jetzt arbeite ich in zwei schüsseln das
heißt ich gebe jetzt zuerst einmal das
eiweiß in die röhre schritte und bei
einem normalen werte wie ich hier
braucht man auch danken backpulver die
gebe ich jetzt als tattoo denn datei
wird durch die butter und den einschnitt
wirklich einfacher gemacht das eiweiß
wird es schön zur einstellung zu
schlagen
wird es der schnee fest jetzt kommt hier
noch der zucker dazu und dann kann es
eben für etwa eine minute weiter rühren
jede station fertig so muss stehen jetzt
nehme ich die platte kommt in eine
separate schüssel und die muss jetzt
auch richtig schön weich sein damit man
sie eben schön schaumig rühren kann also
die weiche butter rein und ich denke da
auch meistens am tag vorher dran und
stellte schon aus dem kühlschrank raus
und bin ich könnte das einfach mit einer
reibe fein hobeln und dann wird die auch
ganz schnell zimmer war jetzt noch
puderzucker reihen und manila extrakt
und jetzt wird die masse für etwa fünf
bis sechs minuten cremig verrührt und
das richtig schön weiß krieg seien
jetzt ist die butter schön weiß cremig
netz kommen die eigene wird ganz langsam
und einzeln dazu
[Musik]
so sieht die eier massa jetzt aus jetzt
kommt das mädel dazu das wird kurz
gesiebt jetzt erstmal noch die hälfte
vom mehl dann vorsichtig unterheben und
dann gebe ich jetzt im wechsel noch die
mensch dazu ihr könnt auch rum nehmen
und dann auch den eischnee und das
restliche mehl
das mehl wird einfach gesund damit keine
geschenke
[Musik]
und ganz zum schluss kann ich jetzt noch
die zucker streusel unterheben
[Musik]
jetzt würde ich den teig in zwei
backformen ein die habe ich beide auf 22
cm eingestellt so habe ich einfach nicht
so viele teig in der form falls ihr nur
eine backform habt dann bereitet erst
die hälfte des tages zu fragt in allen
kuchen und dann die übrige hälfte
so kann man einfach sicherstellen und
das nichts zusammenfällt
und so kann der teig gebacken werden im
vorgeheizten backofen ich werde in der
zwischenzeit später auch noch eine große
menge zu bereiten für die 28er größe und
dann die zeit nutzen für die beko
[Musik]
die zwischenzeit nutze hier klingt es
auch immer aus um die frucht einlagen
herzlich stellt hier mache ich jetzt
himbeer frucht einlagen und dazu gibt es
auch schon ein grundrezept auf meinem
kanal zu machen natürlich zwei größen
einmal für die obere und für die untere
torte mit himbeeren und die vanille so
sehr mag kommt dann machen die extra
dazu frucht einlagen sind immer richtig
toll weil man so die torte schön
fruchtig machen kann aber kein rohes
obst keine rohen früchte mit dabei hat
die einfach matschig werden und deswegen
können die auch schon drei tage im
voraus zubereitet werden eingefroren
werden und die torte hat später richtig
schöne feine schichten ignoriert
maschine einfach
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich schon dass ag mit den
himbeeren verbinden sind ja beides
heißer massen also einfach rein schütten
und ak nehme ich hier immer ganz gerne
weil es einfach die pflanzliche variante
ist zu schneller team und bei der frucht
anlage braucht man jetzt einfach eine
form wo man es rein fühlen kann entweder
ein tortenring oder einen teller mit
frischhaltefolie natürlich ausgekleidet
und die frucht einlagen müssen immer
kleiner sein als die torte selbst die
habe ich jetzt etwas 16 und halb
zentimeter für die kleine torte und hier
etwa 22 für die große und die werden
dann abgekühlt und eingefroren
[Musik]
jetzt kommt das wichtigste nämlich die
zahl 18
hier habe ich mir schon eine schablone
gemacht die 81 sondern 18
und ich habe mich einfach im cache bord
das hat jetzt 20 zentimeter im
durchmesser so weiß ich ungefähr wie
groß die torte ist diesen bisher größer
und kann dann dementsprechend so viel
deko dann machen die 18 mache ich jetzt
aus pinkeln von war und damit davon dort
aushärtet und die zahl aufstellen kann
nämlich noch blüten passt
ich habe ich einfach das verhältnis zwei
zu eins also die hälfte blüten passte
und einen teil vom dorf das ist schön
verkneten und dann aufräumen
jetzt können die entweder die
modelliermasse die entstanden ist
ausrollen auf einen zentimeter stärke
und dann mit hilfe von schablonen die
zahl eins und die acht ausstechen
oder hier geht so eine zweite variante
ihr braucht gar keine schablonen ihr
rollt die modelliermasse einfach zu
einem langen strang dann den strang
abschneiden und jetzt daraus eine eins
und einer 8 formen
bei der 8 kommt dann hier noch ein
bisschen kleber reihen zum fixieren und
auch hier unten
und egal bei welcher zahl auch immer
jetzt brauche ich noch schaschlikspieß
damit die zahlen später in die torte
gestellt werden können und dann nehme
ich jetzt ein bisschen kleber kommt
kleber an die spitze und die spieße
werden dann von unten ganz groß richtig
rein gesteckt und so kann ich die zahlen
dann über nacht trocknen lassen
[Musik]
jetzt sind die karten an der reihe und
dafür habe ich jetzt hier wieder von
dort mit blüten pasta gemischt und hier
auch verschiedene farben gemacht wie
grün gelb orange pink und so einen
mintgrünen romance blau und jetzt nehme
ich hier jeweils ein kleines stück vom
es zu einer kugel was machst du
rosen und die kugel wird dann etwas
flacher geformt und immer schön
aufpassen dass keine falten drin mit man
kann ich dir schon mal ablegen und jetzt
nämlich eine kleine kugel die auch
leicht flach drücken
also das ist einfach nur schön
dreidimensional aussieht das lege ich
jetzt hier dran wenn hat fantasie
bakterien
[Musik]
ich habe ich hier ganz viele
verschiedene charaktere und die werden
auch gleich zusammengeklebt mit essbarem
kleber jetzt kommen dann noch augen
drauf und dafür nehme ich jetzt hier ein
gold hole ich habe ich einmal eine
kleinere spitze und eine größere jetzt
kann ich damit die vertiefungen für die
augen reindrücken
[Musik]
die kakteen bekomme es nach augen und
die mache ich jetzt aus schwarzer
modelle schokolade schwarze von dauer-
oder blüten pasta wird jetzt auch geben
einfach eine kleine kugel formen dann
etwas kleber in dieser tv und die augen
hinein kleben
[Musik]
jetzt bekommen die kakteen noch
blumentöpfe nicht alle aber ein paar
zumindest die großen und die blumentöpfe
die sehen dann so aus dafür brauche ich
jetzt ein bisschen orange ich kann hier
zu einem langen band zu schneiden
dann bist du jetzt auch nichts auslassen
es geht alles per augenmaß schön gerade
[Musik]
und jetzt hier oben ein bisschen
umschlagen
[Musik]
da kann ich das auch mit dem lineal
immer wieder schön gerade biegen und zum
beispiel so ein kleines rädchen nehmen
zum zahnrad und damit ein bisschen
markieren seiner seite hier auch gerade
wegschneiden
jetzt habe ich hier einfach aus modelle
schokolade so ein kleines kästchen
gebastelt das hast du jetzt auch
befreien
damit können sie umdrehen
kleber bestreichen
[Musik]
der überrest wegschneiden und strom pro
mobilität
[Musik]
jetzt nämlich ein zahnstocher zur hilfe
ein bisschen essbaren kleber es kommt
hier der zahnstocher rein damit der
kaktus einfach einen besseren halt hat
und nicht umfällt und jetzt ganz
vorsichtig hier oben rechts
[Musik]
die weko habe ich jetzt beiseite
gestellt frucht einlagen sind ja auch
schon bereit jetzt geht es ans 100 orte
ich fühle sie mit einer italienischen
mutter queen mit einer himberg remund
ausdruck kommt dann noch eine garage
zuerst bereite ich jetzt die garage vor
da gibt es ja auch schon das grundrezept
spezia weiße schokolade und sahne
die sonne wird kurz aufgekocht über die
schokolade gegossen und dann verrührt
und die muss ich dann in einem kühlen
raum nicht im kühlschrank einfach über
nacht stehen lassen
[Musik]
für die frucht verträgen habe ich die
himbeere
da habe ich jetzt einfach tiefgefroren
in bern genommen weil sie auch günstiger
sind und vor allem schöne reife habs
jetzt aufgetaucht und top solange
einkochen lassen bis fast keine
flüssigkeit mehr vorhanden ist
jetzt habe ich sie noch durch ein
haarsieb gestrichen damit die kern
entfernt werden
die kann ich mit noch morgens in
joghurts oder in den quark einrühren zb
und das ist jetzt das was aus den himba
noch übrig blieb auf 750 gramm und ihr
seht auch schon richtig schön
dickflüssig und fest so dass einfach die
buttercreme gleich nicht flüssig wird
also so fest muss die konsistenz seien
jetzt natürlich schnell abkühlen
die mutter musste ich jetzt in den
kühlschrank stellen damit sie auf
zimmertemperatur kommt denn wir haben
gerade draußen über 30 grad und in der
küche glaube ich knapp 40 grad mehr so
heiß und die mutter war einfach viel zu
weich
die eismasse habe ich jetzt hier schon
geschlagen die ist auch schon
einigermaßen kalt gerührt als zu kalt
ließ und bei den temperaturen geht und
dann kann ich jetzt gleich alles
verbinden und die kompletten
mengenangaben findet ihr auf dem blog
die kalorienangaben habe ich die
tortenböden gut abkühlen lassen und
jetzt nämlich eine torten säge und
schneit es einfach durch das könnte
jetzt entweder zweimal machen oder auch
einmal nur
[Musik]
es werden einfach alle zutaten
miteinander kombiniert also
normalerweise ist die konsistenz ja ein
bisschen fester oder können deutsche
rezept video macht nein das kommt raus
30 und das pink wieder raus und ist auch
zeigt doch gleich unsere unterhose in
die kamera verordnung die zweite kiste
mit bisschen buntwäsche könnte auch die
machen
[Musik]
eine torte befüllt werden ich muss jetzt
ein bisschen schnell arbeiten es ist ein
echt viel zu warm
[Musik]
darauf eine frucht einlage und die muss
wirklich schön klein sein damit sie
nicht nach außen dringt dann wieder
buttercreme drauf streichen
[Musik]
die kommt dann der nächste boden drauf
und so wird die torte scheinen gefüllt
[Musik]
damit es leichter füllen lässt nehme ich
jetzt den tortenring setzt den außen rum
jetzt einfach
[Musik]
wir sind beide torten gefüllt hier kommt
jetzt einen torten retter drauf und
damit sie schön fest werden und nicht
sie dann schön glatt bestreichen kann
kommen sie jetzt über nacht in den
kühlschrank
morgen geht's dann weiter jetzt in die
tat um gut durch gefühlt und jetzt kann
ist sehr schön glatt streichen und
führte von dort vorbereiten dass man mit
der großen an und nehmen sie jetzt
erstmal vom totenbett darunter damit ich
später die torte auch gut stapeln kann
habe ich jetzt hier einfach in kate bush
und es ist minimal größer als die torte
selber da kommt ein bisschen drauf damit
ordentlich runter rutscht
habe es so schön für das so dann auch
knapp
[Musik]
das habe ich hier diesen minimalen rand
vom kickboard jetzt kann ich die ghanas
nehmen und hier an den rand streichen
und dann auch richtig schön setzen
und ich habe schon ein video auf youtube
zeigt wie man mehr rundet orte richtig
schönen glattstreichen
[Musik]
da kann so ein streichen dass er da auch
diese buttercreme verwenden dieser von
dort tauglich aber wir haben ja geradezu
heiße temperaturen da finde ich es immer
besser wenn die torte außen mit garage
überzogen wird weil die garage einfach
nicht so schnell schmilzt der heißen
sonne
[Musik]
jetzt sind die torte gestrichen und
können mit von dort überzogen werden ich
hatte es jetzt auch noch einen
kühlschrank noch immer ganz wichtig dass
die torte wirklich kalt genug ist
hier habe ich jetzt rosinen von dom und
zwar habe ich da rosa und erdbeere
gemischt hier jetzt drei päckchen rosa
und zwei päckchen erdbeere etwa von da
ist nämlich super lecker und durch das
rosa habe ich dann diese tolle farbe
hinbekommen jetzt kann ich das schön
dünn ausrollen und die torte dann damit
überziehen
[Musik]
hier gibt's bei uns nicht so lecker nach
erdbeeren
ich liebe einfach diese app erstellen
sie richtig echte erdwärme echte sap
queries irgendwann dort so gut für die
unsere taten nämlich jetzt hellblau dann
nehme ich jetzt auf 1,25 kilo da werde
ich einfach genug habe zum ausbau und
die habe ich noch einen tupfer grüne
lebensmittelfarbe zugeführt so habe ich
schon leicht winziges ja jetzt wieder
ausbauen und damit die untere pforte
damit vertreiben und zieht jetzt immer
noch ganz viel aus aber man braucht
natürlich viel von dort und was schon
darüber legen kann und die reste kann
man dann einfach luft riecht oder
aufbewahren für mehrere wochen bis
monate zeit
[Musik]
das restliche rosa und etwas vanille von
dort habe ich jetzt damit
mit ein bisschen blüten pasta das war
auch nur übrig und damit über sehe ich
jetzt ein kickboard damit ich später die
torte präsentieren kann
das skateboard wird dann noch ein
bisschen strukturiert und kann dann
trocknen
jetzt geht's bei mir mit der dekoration
weiter die zahlen sind jetzt getrocknet
und die kann man jetzt natürlich so
lassen oder sie noch ein bisschen
betriebsam egal heißt so könnt ihr
entweder das metall ex-premier das ist
wirklich super einfach und zwar einfach
aus der entfernung ein bisschen
schütteln und dann besprühen und dann
bekommen zu einem ganz tollen
glitzereffekt ich habe da 8 kann ich
jetzt nicht sprechen denn ich hab ja
schon ein kaktus rein geklebt sind auch
richtig süß aus später deswegen werde
ich das ganze jetzt bestreichen könnt
ihr zum beispiel die metallic farbe
einfach hier in den deckel rhein
schwimmen und stammende pinsel reingehen
und gestalten
[Musik]
dann möchte reist dann die zahl noch mit
glitzer flakes die kakteen bekommen
jetzt noch ein bisschen farbe dafür
vermisse ich jetzt weiße pulver mit
etwas wasser und schrubber kleine weiße
punkte auf die katzen
damit kann man auch ganz toll die
lichtpunkte in den augen ersetzen mit
etwas trockener lebensmittelfarbe als
mit broten farbpulver topf ist jetzt
noch ein bisschen rouge auf die wangen
wir wissen ja alle kakteen haben jetzt
dekorierte kakteen noch mit kleinen
blumen dafür habe ich auch die
modelliermasse ausgerollt als blumen
ausgesprochen
dann mit perlen rein geklebt und diese
werden danach die kakteen gesetz aus den
restlichen bunten farben mache ich jetzt
noch eine wimpel girlande dafür rolle
ich die ganzen farben dünn aus und
stellte dann die buchstaben aus damit
ich keine fähnchen hinbekommen nämlich
einen runden rosetten ausstecher und
schneidet dann mit einem lineal die
seiten weg jetzt lebe ich mit essbarem
kleber noch die buchstaben auf
[Musik]
und damit das ganze erstmal bleibt
nämlich schnüren
da nehme ich die schlittschuhe schnüren
also die zwar schnell geht genau richtig
schönen bunten farben gruppe ich mal
welche farbe einfach schön flechten aber
damit sie ein bisschen zu dick jetzt
sind wir wenig später auf jeden fall
auch für die deko hängen bleibt
[Musik]
essbarer kleber drauf wir oben natürlich
nur deswegen habe ich das buch sterben
ganz unten platziert und jetzt den
oberen teil einfach kurz umschlagen
[Musik]
nachts mal zu stören
welche farbe egal ein freundschafts an
wand okay halt fenster nicht rächte
wie beim woodstock
doch eine halskette spaß bei der arbeit
der erste gang auf
[Musik]
für heute habe ich jetzt alles erledigt
die torte ist im prinzip eigentlich auch
schon fertig morgen ist die feier von
release achtzehnten geburtstag und ich
nehme jetzt alles mit paketen morgen
früh alles ein
dann fahren wir gemeinsam so willi und
setzte dort dann die torte zusammen
ich bin schon auf meine arbeit für heute
sind weitere galilei daheim jetzt kann
ich die torte zusammensetzen
jetzt streiten sich ein bisschen
buttercreme auf skateboard und da kommt
jetzt die untere torte drauf und hab ich
zu hause schon steht bereit ist in die
stützen denn die obere torte ist also
schwer und ohne stützen würde sie
einfach einsacken also braucht man die
zum stabilisieren
die obere torte setzt sich noch nicht
drauf das kommt gleich jetzt bereite ich
erstmal noch mal eine garage
damit mache ich den grip perfekt
[Musik]
habe ich weniger marsch und dem ist
jetzt ein gefährt mit lebensmittelfarbe
patzte einmal in blau und emma im pick
also mindestlohn und ich weiß nicht ob
ich denn mit ton getroffen habe ich und
wie stelle ich jetzt noch kühl die sind
so ein bisschen zu warm für die torte
für die geländer ich jetzt zwei
strohhalme und hat hier ein bisschen
zucker karamellisieren lassen
und da kann ich jetzt die kette dran
hängen aber ganz vorsichtig karamell ist
über ganz heiß
[Musik]
während die beiden klassen jetzt noch
ein bisschen abkühlen kann ich aber
schon mal die torte dekorieren die
zweite jetzt schon drauf gesetzt die
muss jetzt auch nicht geklebt werden
denn die torte bleibt ja hier also
einmal die 18 direkt rein stecken
[Musik]
the trip die perfekte konsistenz nicht
zu dick und nicht zu dünn und vor allem
nicht heißt jetzt einfach vorsichtig mit
einem löffel auftragen
[Musik]
jetzt ist das eis tragen jetzt nämlich
die kuchen restaurant mit der garage das
dient jetzt als eiskugel
[Musik]
damit aussieht als ob das eis schmelzen
würde über die torte müssen wir
natürlich das blau nehmen den trip macht
ja nur sinn wenn was ruft
es wird cool
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt kann's versteckt werden alle süß
band drauf die kakteen drauf alles was
ich da habe einfach drauf opfers gehört
[Musik]
die tat ist jetzt fertig und sie gefällt
mir richtig gut ich hoffe natürlich dass
lily sich jetzt gleich über die torte
freut sich noch nicht gesehen alle
warten jetzt draußen
ich trage das schwere stück jetzt nach
draußen und falls ihr die torte nach
wacken wollt dann findet er das gesamte
rezept auch sally blog.de die torte
reicht jetzt eigentlich locker für
mindestens 40 personen
weil sie wirklich sehr hohe torte ist
und die wird dann in dünne stücke
geschnitten
also los geht es mit der überraschung
[Musik]
heil angekommen
ich bin gespannt
[Musik]
alles gute zum gefällt sie dir danke